cardinals are looking here with john
gant on the bump take the series using a
lot of the sinker change up got a slider
good curve as well
lifted in the air
right center on the move making the
catch vader
oh what a play harrison banner and right
center in a one-out walk michael
conforto is the batter now
just like this the 2-1 edmond de young
and safe at first then it'll extend the
inning to pete alonso
ground ball force play at second
met strand a runner cardinals coming up
taiwan walker goes to work it'll be his
sixth start for the mets he's one-on-one
with an ara of exactly three tommy
edmund leading the national league in
base hits nice strike three
so walker gets edmond looking and that's
the first out painted his wagon with a
little running fastball here's the o2
swing and a miss strike three that's one
of those newfangled i'll show you about
launch angle deals that pitchers have
subscribed to lately so here's paul
goldschmidt as walker has punched out
the first two
that's in there for a call strike three
and taiwan walker strikes out the side
in the first inning no score after one
john gant faces dom smith to start the
second and he got a
first strikeout for john gann the
breaking ball down in the zone got him
in swing mode here's kevin pillar
slashed the other way by pilar and he's
got himself another hit
so kevin pillar having himself quite a
series he's now hit in five straight
games and got nine for 17. as vr draws a
walk the second one given up by gantt
and the mets have two men on
ground ball
in the hole
force play and got him at second base
key play with the pitcher coming up and
now he has two met strand a pair
they've left three on through two well
we go to the bottom of the second inning
nolan aronado leads off the last of the
second arendano
base hit to right so that's how you do
it that's it they give you a wide open
right side say i will take it and now
paul de young
chopped towards third
and they throw it away arenado on his
way to third base
that'll be an air on vr they have not
played clean baseball to start this
season the mets they have not at all so
runners at the corners and nobody out
and he slashes one knocked down by vr
he's going to go to first with it and a
wide throw but alonso able to stay on
the bag
the cardinals have runners at second and
third one out and the number seven
hitter harrison bader coming up three
for nine in this series double home run
bader with a high fly ball
smith is over makes the catch both
runners will tag one will score
and with that it's a one-nothing saint
louis lee
one-nothing as we go to the third pete
alonzo will bat with two on and one out
he lines one in the center field for a
base hit mcneil will be held up at third
as bader sails one in
and the mets have the bases loaded now
the bases are full for dominic smith
inside corner struck him out
flirting with danger all afternoon early
on in this game and now he's one out
away and now the big hit will have to
come if it comes from kevin pilar
and pilar yanks it down the left field
line will it stay fair it is hooking and
it is caught up against the wall when a
catch
what a catch
a sensational play by justin williams to
leave the bases loaded and john gant
goes out to meet williams at second base
to give him a high five and a pat on the
back wow that was a great play vr mccann
and walker inning number four rolls in
strength three called inside corner vr
swings the bat he is frustrated as he
walks across home plate one out single
to left first pitch to walker swings
away and lines toward right center a
base in so mccann advances to second as
taiwan walker gets the green light
mccann goes to third as mcneal grounds
into a fielder's choice and now runners
on the corners for lindor the pitch a
swing and a miss lindor strikes out gant
leaves two more on and the mets have
stranded eight we go to the bottom of
the fourth one nothing cardinals
ultimate struck out looking his first
time
down on strikes there's a big strikeout
for walker to start the bottom of the
fourth second time he's gotten
goldschmidt five strikeouts now for
taiwan and he's settled in to retire
seven in a row paul de young the batter
two out nobody on
the youngest ground ball is short right
to lindor he's got it takes a step
heaves it to first alonzo to stretch a
bit but he does make the play taiwan
walker's retired 10 in a row one man out
it'll bring up pete alonso
mp gets one to hit but grounds into
third
and arenado makes a high throw and the
tag is too late and alonzo is safe
we've seen ironado make some
on-goal glove type plays in this series
walks the bases loaded so the air in
back-to-back walks and you're asking for
trouble so here's vr who hormoned
yesterday payoff pitch to vr is low ball
four he finally threw him a fast ball he
missed with it it forces in a run and
the game is tied one-to-one all without
benefit of a hit and that will be the
last pitch thrown by gantt as alonso
scores aces remain loaded with one out
james mccann will be the better and cody
whitley the new pitcher three and one to
mccann with the bases full and that's
outside ball four and the mets take the
lead
four consecutive walks the last two have
forced in runs and the mets go in front
two to one and now taiwan walker bats
with the bases loaded struck him out
two outspaces loaded for jeff mcneal one
for three today
hit up the middle
the young
got him by step is mcneil
slides up that first base line the mets
score two runs without a hit and lead
2-1 one man away and the batter now will
be harrison bader
in there strike three called he got him
with a fastball
sixth strikeout for bader two men away
andrew kinser now
breaking ball to kisner popped up near
the pitcher's mound alonzo the first
baseman over to the right of the mound
makes the one-hand catch and that
retires the side so the cardinals go in
order so
another walk and the meds get a lead-off
man on that is the second wild pitch
that he's thrown this year and well
gives the mets another man in scoring
position so here's smith dom gets
curveball and pulls it on the ground to
second
edmonds right there to play it and that
retires the side after the final out in
the top of the six the ground ball by
dominic smith it was just right on time
the rain began to fall so immediately
they put the tarp on the field tarp is
off the field at busch stadium and the
good news is that the rain delay was
short enough that taiwan walker is going
to continue on matt carpenter will be
the pinch hitter and he goes down
swinging on the fastball seven
strikeouts now for taiwan walker that's
14 in a row
set down by walker two up two down dylan
carlson coming up
swinging a high fly ball left field
should be easy for dom smith in a few
steps makes the two-hand catch side
retired so walker shrugs off the rain
delay he's been absolutely brilliant
through six one-hit innings bottom of
the seventh will begin with taiwan
walker on the mound and now they go
upstairs to strike him out walker gets
goldschmidt for the third time
eight strikeouts now for taiwan that
matches his season high and he's now
retired 16 in a row now nolan are in
auto bats
high fast ball popped up
lindor waiting for it to come down
and that's the second out got the
strikeout and now the pop-up and that's
17 straight retired now paul deyoung has
reached on an air and grounded out over
two
young pops it up first base side foul
territory alonzo to his left reaches out
makes the catch on the run and walker
continues to mow through the redbirds
taiwan walker has not allowed a base
runner since the second back-to-back
walks to start the eighth inning that is
ten walks now
in seven innings plus
issued by the cardinal pitching staff
let's see if conforto can do something
with it and conforto loops one into
shallow right that's gonna fall in for a
base hit
mcneal in the third he'll stop there as
carlson picks it up and the mets have
the bases loaded so now a chance for
alonso to get himself a huge hit and
that's two high ball four and it's
a walk festival three runs today all on
bases loaded walks and they lead 3-1 in
the eighth alonzo to first and dom smith
coming up
and dom attacks it and hits it through
the hole for a base sid lendore is in
conforta will stop at third dom smith
gets a hit with a runner in scoring
position to drive in a run and make it
four to one we go to the last of the
ninth diaz on to try to save it one away
here at the bottom of the ninth and now
tommy edmond edmond fights it off for a
base hit tommy edmond put an end to 22
consecutive cardinals batters making out
carlson into center the time run will
come to the plate they got something
going here in the bottom of the night
two outs and arenado up
on the ground to lindor
gets the force play and the ball game is
over
the mitts get a split of the series they
set a club record by leaving 17 on base
but they get a brilliant pitching
performance from taiwan walker and the
mets win it 4-1